each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
the next speaker is also coming about
the University and of course when you
talk about dated since we're talking
about a storage sir will focus on the
organization of storage subsystem every
time your cards talk about this
I'm not going to do that much in failure
okay he's talking excessively about
failure and failure rates which is like
my skate is in peril and so the hotel is
done about what story did so inside the
project you just heard about it we're
interested in the differences in the
computing software structures at scale
there really are sures at very large
scale there's internet services
structures and there's HPC structures
and they're pretty much the only two
large bodies operating at thousands of
nodes and millions of soon to be
millions of course and I'm I got a foot
in both camps and I sort of don't
understand why they're two different
camps and that's the starting point of
our our notion is why should there be
two different camps now what I really
love about all of this kind of stuff is
the dominance of data so I believe that
computers should be built in order to
process data that the data causes you to
say that you need a computer the data
causes you to chip to create and design
the parameters of the computer and
everything else in the compute side is
completely subservient and of course
that is not a very popular view amongst
computer science but it's where we're
going I love this story but I've
probably been told many times but
bringing a large amount of data and
compute to a problem often enhances the
ability of one science team versus a
team that does not have that kind of
ability I believe this will effectively
change the way everybody thinks about
competing to do the best science and
that is they'll have to have the largest
amount of useful data and the ability to
do something with it and I like the
title the unreasonable effectiveness of
data for me this is really good because
I've always cared about the data
management system and the data
management system underneath these
things is therefore going to have to be
very big very flexible and very
affordable some of the data sets that
we've been locally identifying that that
are potentially huge associated with
science not necessarily associated with
any given discipline on how it should be
computed
and I want to go through them but
there's lots and lots of different
scientists that want huge amount of data
for their science problems I look at
this and I say well how do I
differentiate the HPC approach from the
data intensive scalable computing or the
Internet services approach mostly when
people stand up and say look there are
things you can do with hpc you just
can't do with data intensive what
they're referring to is what I would
think of as distributed shared memory
some computation which is based on the
total amount of things you can fit into
memory and that really does want to have
communication cell-to-cell so you need
to have huge memory low latency
communication & Co scheduling of
everything right what we've typically
done in internet services is figured out
how to do out of core operations where
we flow over the data we've broken it up
into big pieces that we can afford to
lose one and restart someplace else so
it turns into a relatively large amount
of post-processing on a relatively small
amount of captured data versus what we
do in hpc however you know if you look
at this community over here there's more
and more data analysis of the result of
simulation and that data analysis is
more and more looking like the same kind
of stuff that we would do initially from
internet services based on transaction
records so convergence is very
reasonable so what I'm going to talk
about specifically in this talk is a
comparison between the storage
subsystems in hpc versus data intensive
and some of their differences and my big
theme in is that many of these
differences are artificial they're based
on the maturity of the code okay my
overriding goal is to get commonality so
I can reuse software why do I want to
reuse software well because the big
picture here is how does a scientist use
a million course effectively without
having to be put their career on the
side and become a computer scientist for
a long period of time and there are many
ways to do it and I'm not going to have
going to try not to have a database
argument here but mainly what I'm going
to say is any programming methodology
that gives you a relatively easy way of
thinking of programming a million cores
on a terabyte or a petabyte of data is a
useful thing to explore at this point
the HPC file systems are much more
mature they have been doing this for 10
to 20 years at relatively large scales
than the data intensive computing
infrastructures and they have always
been dealing with semantics that are
more demanding than we've currently got
in Internet services particularly highly
concurrent and there is the possibility
now of taking it there is a danger even
in hpc it's highly proprietary but there
is a new emerging standard the parallel
NFS which just got its RFC 5661 that can
stand up as being a standards lead
solution to the HPC parallel file
systems and I would argue that would be
a good choice as a substrate for the
data intensive computing as well we want
to reuse the data management tools you
get your petabyte you bring up your your
open source tool to do replication in
three different copies or six different
copies you feel good about the
fundamentals of reliability and then
somebody says what are you doing about
backup how do you deal with this data
coming into the system how do you deal
with the data Kyle falling out of the
system what do you do about replication
and you start designing all sorts of
back-end systems for the data management
that you don't really want to do you
want to have that handled by the
infrastructure that normally handles it
okay and the fundamental problem here is
scale fault domains thousands of fault
domains failures the thing that Peter
doesn't like you and I'll tell a little
story here the projections going forward
through exascale sizes is that the
number of concurrent disk array
reconstructions the way they are
currently being done we'll go from maybe
five percent of the time you're
reconstructing a failed disk to there
are 100 concurrent reconstructions going
on being rebuilt at every time
throughout the lifetime of that system
we will we will probably not get there
because we'll probably do things
differently but if we did them the way
we are right now it would scale to that
what that would mean is the performance
analysis would always be done in the
failure case and you would never bother
with the normal case because you're not
going to experience it much right
that's going to change the way we do
systems so we will struggle hard to
avoid doing that for a while all right
so what we did is we took HDFS which is
the file system inside Hadoop which is
the open-source implementation of
MapReduce and it is nicely layered and
we pulled out the file system separated
Hadoop from HDFS we stuck in PV fsp VFS
apparel virtual file system it is an
open-source hpc system it's used
extensively at Argonne in production so
it's a mature implement implementation
and we don't have a pointer so I'm going
to wander around a little bit sorry
about that you have the top bun okay um
so now this is really all in a Java
layer when in Hadoop HDFS and so what we
did was put in a little shim and that
little shim make so calls to pv FS
primarily what's in that gym is read
ahead and normally you don't do read
ahead in a parallel file system because
it leads to inconsistent data but in the
HDFS world we do right once we have no
problems with inconsistency so they have
no problem reading head aggressively we
pass a file layout information that
allows us to ship compute to the data by
knowing where the data is and we pass in
replication because traditional HPC
pushes replication down into the
subsystem tries to make reliability a
property of the hardware and not a
property the software and the data
intensive systems are making it a
property of the higher level software
the result in short is when you pull it
out of the box this is HDFS you put in
pv FS underneath you go a lot slower
that's not the end of story the read
ahead tuning which isn't that hard gets
half of the difference gone away and
then if you expose the layout position
the other half one way and this is
typical this one is a small system I
think we ran locally not am 45 but it's
it's the same kind of architecture so
the short story here is that there is no
performance difference when Peavy FS is
one exactly the same hardware as HDFS
for HDFS workloads and that can be taken
one of two ways it can be taken that GH
gfs has doing pretty well against the
mature p VFS system and and it can also
be taken that it's not able it doesn't
have any huge advantages over the more
mature software at the same time take it
either way one of the important
differences here is Peavy FS has to be
run on the same nodes to take advantage
of the shipping compute to the data and
that's a really big shift to the way the
hpc systems build compute purses storage
they would always put compute into into
nodes that are primarily doing compute
in storage in two separate nodes why
well because the storage nodes are going
to be used for all the computations for
all the storage everywhere and you don't
particularly want to be turning your
supercomputer into a file server for
someone's outside work but that is
fundamentally what we're doing with with
the more data intensive approach and
it's not bad it's just a big trade-off
the second thing is this way we do
replication okay looking a little closer
there are some interesting differences
the intellectual thing I want to get
across here is in a rewrite of the
system for date of intensive we take and
throw traditional boundaries and api's
and toss them away and solve the problem
differently here's an example of that so
in pv FS as you change the number of
clients that you are reading against the
file the file bandwidth grows linearly
there's more clients reading more
spindles are up and running away you go
everything is evenly loaded you get
every benefit with HDFS as you add more
clients reading you don't get more
bandwidth linearly why because they're
doing random assignment of the blocks to
locations and you don't get every
spindle spun up all the time and you get
congestion so right off the bat with a
workload that is like a traditional file
reading sequentially you lose it quite a
bit in here but this never costs HDFS
any problem because MapReduce doesn't
tend to encourage you to process that
way Map Reduce encourages you to break
down your work into a big pile of queue
of work and hand that Q over to the
MapReduce job scheduler the MapReduce
job scheduler load balances and keeps
everybody busy so it doesn't do the work
at this at the time which causes the
load imbalance
which causes this drop-off it picks
something else further down in the file
and does that now because it'll keep the
spindles all going the net result is
HDFS doesn't see any slower processing
when you're going to read the whole data
in whatever order the MapReduce job
scheduler decides to run it in so that
boundary effectively says yes this is a
bad layout from the point of view of
traditional read access patterns but if
you know you're going to use the job
load balancing and job control language
that MapReduce gives you you don't have
any you don't suffer from that and
there's a lot of benefits to random
allocation because you don't have things
in the wrong place when you lose
something and you have to rebalance it
later on the big difference of course is
that HDFS rights once and then doesn't
write again it doesn't support
concurrent writing or even rewriting so
the result is is that if you have to
write something then the completion time
of writing a large file in HDFS just one
of them is terrible because one node has
to read the whole thing in and copy it
to another location or regenerate all
the data one writer for one file the
network whereas PVF s of course can do
this in parallel there's no problem the
net result of that is that HDFS trains
its users to manage their data
differently the typical HDFS user thinks
of a large file as a directory with a
whole lot of pieces and they pick up the
directory and they move that around
because now I can copy it with MapReduce
firing off a job copying each little
piece and I get the full bandwidth of
the system right it is a limitation of
the underlying file system that they're
changing with the behavior of their
users right it's currently not much of a
problem but it if you do want that large
file and in hpc we see checkpoint users
that generate checkpoints arguing
strongly that they don't want to manage
the 10,000 files of the 20,000 files
they want to manage this one hence they
do want the concurrent writing so we did
a comparison up on yahoo and 45 which is
now part of the and i just pulled this
off today
yeah good so thank you oh okay so you
did a comparison of grappling sort two
of the class of benchmarks for HDFS and
gfs before it on the yahoo IM 45 m 45 is
500 nodes eight way parallel it's been
available for research in disk like
computing to CMU for the past two years
year and a half and we did this by
spinning off and a separate HDFS on it
and a PDF s on top of it just all run
underneath the their environment and
what I wanted to show is for reading
data there's just no difference for for
sort which is does a lot of writing
there's a big difference and the big
difference corresponds to the number of
copies that are made and the network
bottlenecks so in m45 you have a
relatively slow Network compared to the
amount of disk bandwidth it's inside so
the disk bandwidth locally is free
compared to the network bandwidth so
HDFS when it goes to write three copies
puts one locally and writes to remotely
the local one is effectively free
causing the significant difference in
here that this is a complicated thing
that free one is would create massive
imbalance if you were writing a few
large files but of course the users have
been taught to carry around a directory
full of a lot of comparable size objects
so writing one locally as long as you
have lots and lots of MapReduce is
writing a lot a lot of relatively small
things load balances that file as well
so a lot of behavioral characteristics
and mix things that are going on here
also the network limitation is not
fundamental it isn't you don't say it is
a disk system because it is network
limited we're seeing in the cluster that
we built yes we have one in here that is
dual one Giggy but we also built one
with 10 gige and our 10 gige
implementation can write remotely as
fast as it writes locally and you take
away that bottleneck and that difference
goes away it's also the case that the
ether community there's a little two
papers i can point to now have
covered batteries in closed networks so
as the HPC world has learned along the
time ago if you want to hide bisection
bandwidth you can build a two-level
routing Network close tree is the is the
classic one the the ether world has
figured out that they can do the same
thing and so the cost of providing
higher bisection bandwidth is not
necessarily anywhere near as much as you
might think it would be okay so P VFS
HDFS as underlying file systems if I
ignore the replication they're largely I
can make them do almost the same thing
all right now the replication so HDFS
does triplication it does triplication
gfs before it did triplication this is
you know from my background as a raid
person from the 80s a totally
unacceptable overhead that when you
think you and that my students did this
recently they said oh we've got to move
around a big pile of data it's about
twenty percent of the capacity of the
storage so that's you know one-fifth of
each of the disk that's not going to be
too bad but HDFS is going to triplicate
everything so it's sixty percent of the
capacity of the entire storage that
turns out to be quite an issue alright
so so why is it that we're paying a
triplication overhead the main reason is
simplicity so when you were to when you
do raid over the nodes rather than raid
in in a hardware subsystem you're
exposed to all the failure modes of all
the components not just the disk failure
modes all the computing failure modes as
well and that makes it messier so so
I've dealt with this we built a raid
over objects at penn asus of the company
i started and you can do it you can do
it at giant scale but it is quite a bit
more complex than what gfs and HDFS
actually did what they actually did was
they simply write three copies and it's
expensive it makes you know lots of
transfer it uses a lot of space but the
repair and reconstruction operation that
the guaranteeing your date is there is
moved off the critical path all of the
reconstruction is done in a background
thread so you write a lot of copies so
you don't think you're going to ever be
threatened and then if a few of them go
away there's a background thread that
runs around discovers that you may not
have full replication pics those items
and makes more replicas right and it's
being done effectively more slowly than
a nutritional rate traditional raid
would work really hard as soon as the
failure occurred to repair it because
they would be trying to operate with a
little smallest number of clean copies
and if they're operating with the
smallest number of clean copies then
there's a fear that you will be in high
level of vulnerability if you don't
clean up fast what what this code did
was say well yeah that's true let's make
more copies so that we can tolerate that
and then we'll do it all in the
background all right but that overhead
the space overhead still too much so
what we're going to try to do here in is
put a raid algorithm into HDFS to give
you back that space and at the same time
learn from the deferred asynchronous
encoding and recovery all right so what
we're going to do is we're going to
write three copies fire them out there
right off the bat then the background
job is going to run around find places
where there's three copies and encode
them down to one car 85 two copies in
raid 5 or a raid 6 implementation so
we'll still have the high protection
we'll still get the same amount of
bandwidth but we will delay the encoding
operation take it off the critical path
for simplicity there's a complexity here
I've got all these users that are
trained to treat a large file as a
directory of 10,000 little files so it
turns out that i don't have nice big
files to compute Radian so i'm going to
have to compute rate across lots of
files and that's going to make a mess of
my delete but i'm not going to worry
about that much here so we we have built
this the first one we built in a class
project here last year was simply to
replace one copy with raid 5 so you
wrote 3 copies you go around you find
three copies and you take you leave two
of them in place and you delete one and
replace it with the with the XOR of a
bunch of other nodes we would go around
and find a server that had the things
that we want to compress already local
so we wouldn't use the network that was
a search process of finding
a set of things that we can compress
locally and it you know doesn't change
the performance of the system as you
would imagine and saves the space as you
would imagine we stopped because you
can't extend that very well to higher
levels of protection the the algorithm
for searching for the right combination
of blocks on an individual node that can
protect against two failures is getting
growing exponentially so we didn't want
to do that search anymore and what we
did to instead was to change the
allocation decision on when you first
create the data so it's pre Alec pre
decided what you're going to group
together these are code words and then
we would go around and afterwards when
those code words are all filled in
compress them away there are new
interesting things in when we did raid
in the early 90s we were deeply worried
about the small right problem the small
right problem is when you change only
one word in a stripe then you have to
update the parity and you can either do
that by reading everything in computing
and writing up the new parity or by
noticing which you toggled in the
data and toggling the corresponding bits
but we have that problem all over again
in this scheme in deletion so if we've X
Ord objects together that don't get
deleted together than to recover the
space i have 2x or them out of the freed
up space out of the the datasets so
we're looking at we're looking at ways
to use this freedom in asynchronous
encoding to delay encoding so we can
have triplication for applications that
can benefit from it and to delay
deletion so that we can not do the XOR
encoding so this stuff the codes is a
simple code I actually the difference in
the codes is triplication you write
three copies of everything raid 5 plus
mirror you have two copies you do a
parody and the raid 6 is the data and
then to parity after we did this when we
gave a talk in June at open cirrus and
the HDFS developers were in the room and
they told us in September they liked the
idea and they built it so HDFS has
released this coding as a background or
a compression of space for Apache hdf
essence the fastest tech transfer I've
ever done
the raid 6 that we're currently working
on is now implemented in HDFS and here's
an example with what was in the room
earlier I ran this we take a 512
gigabytes of data it gets triplicated up
to fifteen hundred gigabytes when it
gets created and then this this shows
you the compression background
compression job launching up and
compressing away roughly 400 gigabytes
in the raid 5 plus Miriam which HDFS is
now doing and seven hundred gigabytes of
data in the raid 6 and you know it it
grows at about we can do about 4
gigabytes the five gigabytes a second in
this system so the compression can
consume all of the bandwidth in the
system compressing the data way it's not
doing it remotely it's doing it locally
so it's not stealing the network's
bandwidth the net effect of this is that
we can get the space back while
preserving the opportunity of having
triplication for simplification and for
multiple choices of reading we get to
decide when we do this and so we can
pick files that we want to leave
triplicated because they're hotter and
they need they would like more spindles
for access or because we think they're
going to be reused again and we want
that opportunity all right I think I'm
about done and I may be actually on time
so what we've done is we start to look
at exploring the differences in the
software substrates and infrastructures
for big data really big data for hpc and
discs and they're not as big as you
might think it's more property of the
maturity of the code the the right right
once by exactly one node is the kind of
semantics that you would expect users to
slowly but surely demand go away and
concurrent right we'll need to be
supported we see that already at Google
anecdotal comments about that kind of
requirement from their users our
directions what we'd like to do is to
integrate the best of both into our
solutions first of all by allowing you
choice in the substrates but then also
by maturing the like taking raid into
HDFS is maturing it to a more hpc level
quality and then towards richer
structure a lot more metadata
we've got projects doing directories to
millions billions and trillions of
entries directories that replicate the
attributes so that they can operate like
tables for storage management and if
they do it for the extended attributes
they could be tables for user
applications as well okay I'm done I
don't want to steal Alex's time no thank
you